year one of the biden administration is
now in the books
one year ago the president of the united
states was inaugurated he was handed a
working vaccine
he was handed a distribution plan for
that he was handed peace in the middle
east he was handed a fairly stable
situation in afghanistan he was handed a
russia and chinese
move that had been largely blocked
russia and china were at least somewhat
stagnant
and all of this was really easy like if
you go back and you listen to my
predictions for joe biden here's what i
said when he was inaugurated i said that
for the first two years you'd have a
pretty easy time of it because the
economy was going in going to go into a
natural recovery we had had an
artificial coma for the economy we were
already coming out of it by q4 of 2020
and certainly 2021 was going to be a
massive boom year followed by 2022 which
would also be a massive boom year and
almost nothing joe biden could do could
stop that well wrong i was it turns out
that joe biden could in fact stop that
joe biden was handing peace in the
middle east and i said i'm not sure how
he can really screw that up because it's
not like the iranians are on the verge
of signing a deal with the united states
how can you screw that up well he has
somehow
managed to screw that up as well i i
said you know joe biden
even joe biden isn't stupid enough
to be weak with china and russia i mean
at least joe biden is going to be
somewhat
yeah no so here is the thing
joe biden has had the worst first year
of any president in american history
any president in american history there
are only two exceptions william henry
harrison because he was dead after 40
days because he went out in the rain and
they got pneumonia and died and james
garfield was shot to death those are the
only two dudes who had a worse time of
it than joe biden in his first year
there are other presidents who have had
bad first years don't get me wrong
herbert hoover was hit with the great
depression in 1929 and then his response
was was bad but that was an extraneous
circumstance that impacted his
presidency that was something unexpected
right that was a circumstance that sort
of fell on him same thing with abraham
lincoln abraham lincoln's first year
half the country seceded that really
wasn't because of abraham lincoln that
wasn't his fault he was handed a really
bad situation
year one of the george w bush
administration gets september 11th
joe biden hasn't had any of those things
joe biden was handed peace joe biden was
handed a track a natural track to
prosperity all he had to do was be what
he already was which was a dead person
that's all he had to do ironically if
joe biden had william henry harrison's
first year he'd still be a popular
president
because joe biden was elected to be not
alive he was elected to be
a house plant as i say a barely alive
thing that doesn't speak very much and
blocks the water stains that's pretty
much all he was there to do president
house plan and somehow he's managed to
blow this in historic fashion it is the
greatest self-inflicted wound i have
ever seen a president commit
and that includes president trump if
president trump spent several years
completely undermining the
accomplishments of his own
administration because he couldn't stop
his fingers from hitting buttons on
twitter
okay but here's the thing trump was
unpopular the day he came into office
joe biden was wildly popular when he
came into office and somehow joe biden
has managed to make himself an
extraordinarily unpopular president to
the point where quinnipiac polls yeah
they're slight outliers but only slight
have them in the low 30s
i mean look at let's look at the
presidential approval ratings for for
example donald trump okay we'll use
trump
as the contrast point because of course
according to the left trump was the
worst person in america
okay so
right from the outset donald trump did
not have one day of his presidency where
he was in the black in his approval
rating he did not have one net positive
day in his presidency where he was
on top in the approval rating
in day one
day one he was almost even he's like 45
positive 45 percent negative and
immediately within like the first couple
of weeks he had shifted to 49 negative
and like 46 positive
and then he just kind of stayed there
for his entire presidency
he had some ups he had some nouns
when it was really bad he had up to 58
of people disliking him and and 39 of
people liking him
but by the end of his first year he was
writing about 54 disapproval and 42
percent approval and he's underwater by
10 points 12 points by the end of his by
the end of his first year
and now here is joe biden's approval
rating
this is unbelievable it really is it's
incredible
so he starts off with a 55 56 approval
rating only 36 percent of americans say
they disapprove of joe biden
and pretty quickly you start to see
these lines narrow
right but but they're not narrowing to
the point where he's anywhere near
negative territory by the time you hit
in the end of july
he's he's kind of around 45 disapproved
but he's still got 51 approval rating
there's a swing of about three points on
average like a a mild decrease in his
approval rating and then comes
afghanistan
which is when the president of the
united states decides to shoot his
entire administration directly in the
face and when i say shoot his
administration in the face what i really
mean is get 13 american service people
killed abandoned 19 million women to to
abject sex slavery and allow a bunch of
8th century barbarian cavemen to overrun
a country and take all of america's
leftover military equipment
it turns out americans don't like that
sort of thing and so joe biden's
disapproval rating now spikes
into the into the plurality position of
the american people
by the time you hit september which is
exactly when this happens right the end
of august the the beginning of time you
see this giant spike in the disapproval
rating
over the course of late august by the
time you hit the beginning of september
joe biden is now at 48 disapproved and
48 and 48 approved
and then it just gets worse it just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse
for joe biden so this is the thing
donald trump started off bad and he
ended bad in terms of the disapproval
rating joe biden
started off really popular
and is really really unpopular right now
because he's crappy at this job he is
just garbage at this job as barack obama
once famously stated don't underestimate
joe's ability to f things up
don't underestimate it again
look back at the trump chart for just
one moment because the swing is what
matters here
the swing here is from about 45
approved
and 45 disapproved to 52 disapprove okay
so that is about a
seven point swing right 45 to 52 over
the course of year one a seven point
swing in the negative direction for
president trump over the course of year
one now look again at the joe biden
chart okay this joe biden chart shows
a swing from 56
approved to 42 a 14 point negative swing
okay so trump got seven points less
popular over the course of his first
year joe biden got 14 percent less
year
that's how bad this guy is at this
he's just awful
and we're gonna go through where things
stand year one of the abiding and all of
this is self-inflicted guys this is all
because joe biden is an incompetent
buffoon it's because as nate silver
suggests it's not that joe biden was
ever a moderate it's just that joe biden
was always dead center of the democratic
party and the democratic party has gone
completely nuts the democratic party's
entire theory of politics is that
everything was crazy because of just
trump if it weren't for trump we'd be
back to normal right trump was insane
and it was all about the the affect it
was all about the tweeting and all about
the attitude and all about the crazy
jokes and all about the bleeding from
whatever and all that kind of stuff okay
and this led them to believe that so
long as the president of the united
states
didn't say things like that they could
do anything they wanted and people would
just be like well i guess things are
still sane
no
wrong it turns out there are two forms
of political crazy one form of political
crazy is going out there and ripping on
mexican judges for no reason and that's
kind of like
mildly political crazy because most
people are just like that's you know
that's kind of nutty behavior but it has
no impact on my life then there's true
political craziness which is boys should
be girls and girls should be boys
everybody who disagrees with me wants
jim crow
what if we pour money onto a gasoline
fire of inflation
and what if we just surrender to china
and russia
in turn what if we just give afghanistan
to the tower like just give it to them
for no reason
here
have afghanistan that's a form of crazy
that has real impact on people's lives
as opposed to you know the bad tweets
and democrats failed to recognize that
they thought so long as they slapped a
kindly old face
on an insane agenda everything would be
fine rongo and it turns out all that
happens is that people begin to realize
that the kindly old face ain't so kindly
when the agenda is really nefarious and
joe biden is is having a terrible
terrible first year mark these and has a
very good column over at the washington
post all about this he says this is the
lived reality millions of americans are
facing a year after a year of biden's
presidency inflation has reached a
40-year high and we have a massive labor
shortage with more than 10 million
unfilled jobs biden signed a partisan
1.9 trillion coveted relief bill in
march when omicron arrived there weren't
enough coronavirus tests or therapeutics
schools are closing again emergency room
visits for suspected suicide attempts by
adolescent girls have jumped 51 from
2019 to 2021 at least 12 major cities
broke annual homicide records in 2021.
we are experiencing the worst border
crisis in american history and a surge
of deadly fentanyl crossing the southern
border has helped fuel an increase of 30
percent in overdose deaths in the past
year the disastrous retreat from
afghanistan projected weakness on the
world stage and emboldened russia to
amass troops along its border with
ukraine putting us on the knife's edge
of a land war in europe and while biden
promised in his inaugural address to put
his whole soul into uniting the country
he just gave a speech comparing millions
of americans to segregationists and
traitors
yeah that's that's a pretty
bad record that's a pretty bad record
now biden is trying to happy talk his
way through this thing
he's doing the obama routine which is
the people just don't understand him
this is obama's routine every time he
did something unpopular be like well i
just didn't explain it well enough the
american people if they understood what
i was doing they would love it and the
american meal like no we we understand
just what you were doing and we do not
love it as it turns out
and then you get the same routine from
biden well if i just ah come on you know
you know man
if you help me explain these policies
then travel to tables
come on up here kamala
like oh
yeah this is that that's going to work
but even elizabeth warren who is
full-fledged terrible at this
the the chief
biden critic from the left in the senate
even elizabeth warren
how bad is she she she um even she can't
answer if joe biden is up to the job
she's asked like is joe biden up to the
job for the job and she had reservations
let me ask you about 2024 do you believe
that president biden is up for the job
president biden's running for reelection
i expect to support him
his approval ratings are some of the
lowest that they've been for a very long
time i i understand that but remember
we've just finished the first quarter
we're just starting into the second
quarter here so we've got a lot of time
a lot of work in front of us i love that
like so do you think he's up to the job
well he is running for re-election like
says is he good at this like well
there's time and time exists
i like how they flash his approval
rating on the screen according to that
cbs news poll by the way he's gone from
61 approval to 44
yeah those are not good numbers gang
there's a really bad number so the good
news is the white house has found a
reason to pivot they want to pivot pivot
pivot pivot they're like ross in the
stairwell with the couch pivot we have
to pivot
according to nbc news white house plots
public reset as biden's agenda fails i
love this i love it so much every time
the newspapers start talking about how a
politician needs to reset how a
politician needs to rejigger their comms
what they really mean is this politician
is super bad at it and this is what you
hear from kamala harris's team every 20
minutes
like almost on the dot they just set a
timer on their watch it's been 20
minutes time to reset kamala's calm
strategy and kamala's over in the corner
saying uh it is it is time
to
do what we have always done and
time
is with a clock
and her team's like okay it's been 20
minutes time to reset that comms she's
over there
guys it isn't the comms you're bad at
this it's not yours it's not your
communication strategy it's that your
policies suck they're bad
they're bad
i mean joe biden's entire calm strategy
during his campaign was what if i sit in
a basement and eat oatmeal and watch
matlock and he won okay so like it's not
about the comms it's about you sucking
at this
i'm not sure you could be worse at this
if you tried to be bad at it it's
incredible okay so according to nbc news
it's time for a reset it's a reset guys
biden's reset plan senior administration
official said is to make his
conversations with members of congress
less of a public priority and to
emphasize spending more time
communicating directly with americans
yeah that's going to go well because
he's done a great job of that so far you
know every week he gets on your tv and
falls asleep he gets on your tv he's
like uh covert is then the unvaxxed are
let's let's hit them with my with my
walker i'm gonna hit them with my work
and americans like that's not he didn't
that's that's not good he said well if
you don't you don't like that
here i am on your tv again and i think
that you want to re-enslave black people
and answer
when i don't say that nope not doing it
not that that's not helping joe
who what if i what if i say that that
you guys are basically
no this isn't going to work joe biden is
a bad communicator he's very very bad at
this
this is the the part that's so funny is
every he's a master communicator the
dude ran for president 83 times he lost
all of the times the only reason anyone
even knows joe biden's name right now
other than as the the foolish
plagiaristic senator who had to drop out
of a presidential race once and got
shellacked every other time he ran and
was a senator from a state that is
mainly run by credit card companies
the only reason anyone has ever heard of
joe biden is because barack obama needed
a buffoonish old white man to be his
vice president now sometimes i say that
that kamala harris was an affirmative
action pick because she was because joe
biden said i need a black woman joe
biden was also an affirmative faction
pick barack obama was like what if i
just take a stayed old white man so that
i look moderate
that was pretty much his agenda
and joe biden continued to fail upward
the only reason that joe biden is
president right now is because barack
obama picked him for his vice president
and then his main competition in a
democratic primary was a senile old
communist
and then his main competition in the
presidential race
was a guy
who just
blurred all over twitter every two
minutes like that is the only reason
that this idiot is president of the
united states and like what if he talked
more to the america you go for it man
put him on the tvs every day more of him
he does a spectacular job
first rule of holes stop digging but joe
biden is out there with a spade digging
just all the way to china
there is a recognition we need to change
the dynamic a senior administration
official told nbc news adding that biden
has told aids and lawmakers he intends
to make the shift there's nothing that
joe biden does better than than sticking
and moving that's what he's great at
part of the goal is to shed the growing
image that biden is approaching the
presidency like a member of the senate
where he spent more than three decades
he's mindful he doesn't want to send the
message his role is to be legislator
chief another senior administration
official said biden's advisors are
looking at a variety of ways for him to
engage more with americans officials
said there's no agreement yet about what
the alternatives might entail he can
only eat ice cream so many times
he can only run naked after his dog from
the shower like so many times
well there is unity among advisors about
having biden talk to more people
directly another official said there's
no agreement about whether the effort
will work no there is it's not going to
work i'm just going to put it it's not
going to work
spoiler alert joe biden talking to
humans not anything that works
changing the white house strategy to
engage more directly with americans is
an evergreen reset plan that has been
activated by previous presidents who
have found themselves in politically
precarious moments for biden that moment
has arrived earlier than his team
expected after early momentum from his
sweeping safety net bill
presidential historian michael buschloss
said oftentimes in modern history when a
president has frustrations and drops in
the polls the president will say it's
now time for me to talk over the heads
of the elites and talk directly to the
people to convince them that what i'm
trying to do is right
yeah the problem is that biden can't
talk anymore he just grunts and makes
noises
biden has struggled to gain his footing
on the coronavirus pandemic which he
promised to get under control and
ultimately defeat he's also been
hampered by the collapse of bill back
better while some of biden's aides have
expressed concern
they're very concerned that he is
seemingly bogged down at the white house
giving too many one-dimensional speeches
from washington instead of showcasing
what they see as his greatest political
strength empathy and an ability to
connect with ordinary americans that is
gone he blew it up it's over for him and
this is why he's not going to recover
the reason he's not going to recover is
because once you blow the empathy line
it ain't coming back
once it has been revealed that you care
less about american soldiers dying in
afghanistan then you reaching a pull-out
by an arbitrary date so that you can
celebrate yourself as some sort of grand
peacemaker which is what happened in
afghanistan that ain't coming back
joe biden captain empathy was always
bullcrap but it certainly is not coming
back now and when he started defending
his action in afghanistan
and and dead service members in
afghanistan by citing the fact that his
son died of brain cancer like no none of
that works and it ain't coming back and
it is over for him
he's still got to be president for three
years but that guy is a lame duck right
now
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe